good morning it's great to be back at
London Tech week and what I think is a
moment of huge opportunity
we are an island of innovation but at A
Moment Like This when the tectonic
plates of Technology are shifting not
just in AI but in Quantum synthetic
biology semiconductors and much more
we cannot rest satisfied with where we
stand
we must act
and act quickly if we want not only to
retain our position as one of the
world's Tech capitals
but to go even further and make this the
best country in the world to start grow
and invest in Tech businesses
that is my goal and I feel a sense of
urgency and responsibility to make sure
that we seize it
because one of my five priorities is to
grow our economy
and the more we innovate the more we
grow
but this isn't just about economics like
you I believe that Innovation is one of
the most powerful forces for
transforming people's lives
and right now there is an opportunity
for human progress that could surpass
the Industrial Revolution in both speed
and breadth
I believe the UK can achieve this goal
because we start from a position of
strength
we've created
134 unicorns in the last decade
third in the World Behind only the US
and China
we're one of the most digitally literate
Societies in the world
with a higher percentage of stem
graduates than the US and four of the
world's top 10 universities
we've got extraordinary strengths in
fintech cyber and creative Industries
and Engineering biology where from the
creek and the biobank to deepmind's
Alpha fold we're pushing at the
boundaries of what is possible in health
and the UK is the best place in Europe
to raise capital
with more invested in Tech here than in
France and Germany combined
but today
I want to answer a simple question
what's the single most important reason
innovators like you should choose this
country
the answer is leadership
do you trust the people in charge to
really get what you're trying to do
with this government and with me as your
prime minister you can
judge us not by our words but our
actions
it's this government that's building the
most pro-investment tax regime
that's increasing public r d investment
to record levels that's making our Visa
system for international Talent one of
the most competitive in the world
we're overhauling our listing rules to
make it easier for companies to raise
Public Funding and changing our pension
rules to unlock new private capital
and we're changing the way government
itself works
I created a brand new Department focus
on science Innovation and Technology
with a mission to do things differently
from bringing in World leading experts
to taking more risks in support of
innovation
and when the moment came it was this
government that acted to rescue Silicon
Valley Bank
so today I'm proud to announce the
launch of HSBC Innovation banking the
most significant Global Tech Bank
combined with hsbc's Firepower and
headquartered here in the UK
and of course
it's the UK where Google chose to bring
together its entire AI division
under the leadership of a Brit Demis
asabis at Google deepmind
and if our goal is to make this country
the best place in the world for Tech
A.I is surely one of the greatest
opportunities before us
as Chancellor
I double the number of AI scholarships
because even back then I recognized the
potential of AI as a general purpose
technology
now with most things in life
the more you learn about them the less
magical they appear
but the more we learn about Frontier
Technologies like AI the more they widen
our Horizons
already we've seen AI help the paralyzed
to walk
and discover superbug killing
antibiotics
and that's just the beginning
combined with the computational power of
quantum we could be on the precipice of
discovering cures for diseases like
cancer and dementia
or ways to grow crops that could feed
the entire world the possibilities are
extraordinary
but we must and we will do it safely
I know people are concerned
the very pioneers of AI are warning us
about the ways these Technologies could
undermine our values and freedoms
through to the most extreme risks of all
and that's why leading on AI also means
leading on AI safety
so we're building a new partnership
between our vibrant Academia brilliant
AI companies and a government that gets
it
and we'll do that in three ways
first we're going to do Cutting Edge
safety research here in the UK
with a hundred million pounds for our
expert task force we're dedicating more
funding to AI safety than any other
government
we're working with the frontier Labs
Google deepmind open Ai and anthropic
and I'm pleased to announce they've
committed to give early or Priority
Access to models for research and safety
purposes
to help build better evaluations and
help us better understand the
opportunities and risks of these systems
second AI doesn't respect traditional
National borders
so we need Global cooperation between
nations and labs
just as we unite through cop to tackle
climate change
so the UK will host the first ever
Summit on global AI safety later this
year
I want to make the UK not just the
intellectual home but the geographical
home of global AI safety regulation
and third
we're going to seize the extraordinary
potential of AI to improve people's
lives
that's why we're already investing
record sums in our capability including
900 million pounds in compute technology
and two and a half billion in quantum
and we're harnessing AI to transform our
Public Services
from saving teachers hundreds of hours
of time spent lesson planning
to helping NHS patients get quicker
diagnoses and more accurate tests
AI can help us achieve the Holy Grail of
public service reform better more
efficient services
so this is our strategy for AI to lead
at home to lead overseas and to lead
change in our Public Services
all part of how we meet our goal of
making this the best country in the
world for Tech
and let me just conclude with this final
thought
I was recently looking for a collection
held by the British Library
and I saw a letter from Charles Babbage
to the then Chancellor dating from the
1830s thanking him for thundering his
Difference Engine the Forerunner of the
modern computer
that was a decisive moment
the British government broke with the
conventions of the time and for a decade
backed this breakthrough technology
we're at a similar moment today
and I'm determined that when future
researchers visit the British library in
200 years time
they will discover that this government
and all of us here in this room
met this moment
with the same courage
vision
and determination
thank you
[Applause]
thanks well thanks for being here prime
minister it's uh fantastic to hear your
enthusiasm for AI and the role the UK
can play on the global stage to steer it
successfully for the world and I've
really appreciated our conversations
we've had over the last few weeks about
how we can develop AI both boldly but
also responsibly
and I think it's important that
government and Industry work together on
this and this is why I think London Tech
week is really important for giving us a
platform for exchanges just like this
over the next few years as the Prime
Minister said I think AI is clearly
going to offer some incredible
opportunities to make live better and at
Google deepmind we're particularly
excited about how AI can help Advance
science and medicine the energy transfer
to transition and improve the lives of
billions of people
so prime minister I was wondering what
do you think are the biggest
opportunities for AI to make a positive
impact in the UK well first of all
thanks Dennis for having me and
congratulations on everything you're
doing you know I think if I think about
it there's there's the obvious economic
one yeah I talked about AI being a
general purpose technology and this idea
of
every job essentially having AI as a
co-pilot just making everyone's job a
little bit easier a little bit more
productive and that replicated across an
entire economy obviously has enormous
potential to change how we do things so
I think that's probably the first one
beyond that in public services health
and education
like in health we're already seeing at
the promise of what AI can do whether
it's new drug Discovery or helping
doctors do surgery more accurately and
faster or indeed detect Cancers and
other things much earlier than they
otherwise would and we're just at the
beginning of the Innovation that's
happening there's something you know
well with Alpha fold on the drug
Discovery side so that's it to me seems
potentially transformative and education
is is the thing that I'm most excited
about because the thing I'm most
passionate about you know I always say
that there's not many things that are
silver bullets in public policy but
world-class education is probably the
closest we have to it's the best way to
spread opportunity to reduce inequality
and the power of AI to you know reduce
teachers workloads and burdens lesson
planning marking but also to provide
personalized learning for each
individual which we know when it comes
to tutoring is so powerful now
technology from you know how holds out
the promise that every
people every student having a
personalized tutor I think that
potentially is just extraordinary in
terms of the good it can do so those are
probably the things that I'm most
excited about yeah it's fantastic I mean
I agree with all of those things and I
think this is the potential actually
specifically in the UK and and also
London of fusing together AI with all of
the great strengths we have in many
other sectors like fintech and biology
like you said gaming all of these other
sectors where AI I think can have some
you know massive Transformations so how
do you think um the UK you know we can
make the UK the best place in the world
to both start and scale up tech
companies
I hear this a lot I think the first
thing to say is we're already a great
place to scale up a tech business and I
mentioned the stat in my remarks if you
look at the last decade more unicorns in
this country than anywhere other than
the US and China so I think that's a
pretty good record and a good base for
us to start from but obviously we need
to keep doing more we need to keep
pushing ourselves you know the first
thing is people
and there's a extraordinary start
something like half of all of our
fastest growing Innovation businesses
have a foreign-born founder so that
tells you you need a visa system that
attracts the best and the brightest to
the UK and I think we've got one whether
it's the new scale-up Visa that I
introduced as Chancellor for companies
who are scaling up to get the talent
they need whether it's our innovator
founder Visa which is globally extremely
competitive or the high potential
individual Visa that I created which
essentially says if you graduated from a
global top 50 University just come to
the UK you don't need a job offer we
just want to make sure that you can
speak English and you have a certain
amount of money to support yourself but
otherwise we just want you here because
we think it will be additive to our
economy that's a massive we're open for
business sign
um to the world's most talented and I
think that's important Capital look
we're closing the Gap if you look at VC
funding as a percentage of GDP whereas
you know we had quite a big gap towards
it to the US five seven years ago that
Gap is steadily closing the Charles was
making a ton of reforms with pensions
insurance industry to unlock even more
Capital the thing I'd love to get your
thoughts on though actually is culture
because that I took that from my time
living in California you obviously know
that well as well yeah and the
government can do all these things but
fundamentally it requires the
entrepreneurs
to just keep going to be not content
with building the 100 million pound
business and then the billion pound
business but just to keep growing and
and that I found in California is very
much the attitude it's just the sky is
the limit everyone thinks they can
create a 100 billion dollar company and
actually you know changing that culture
is is tough for government to do but I
don't know what you think about that
yeah that's a that's a heart of it I
totally agree I mean I've seen the whole
um actually transformation in the last
one we started deepmind back in 2010 and
things were very different then I
remember our first investors who were US
based and we had to go to the US to get
our first investment were uh sort of um
suspicious that it you could build huge
deep tech companies anywhere other than
Silicon Valley and I wanted to prove
that that could be done and I hope we
paid our small part in making that
easier now to to and I agree with you
the the environments transformed
completely from back 10 15 years ago I
think it is a lot easier to start uh and
and grow very difficult and very
meaningful deep tech companies
um so you know it's been it's been great
to see that and I think there's a huge
opportunity from here and I also agree
with you that is we have to be open to
Talent from internationally and I think
I think the UK does really well on that
so you mentioned Babbage uh in your in
your opening remarks he's a great hero
of mine but um you know the UK has
always had a rich science and and Tech
Heritage how do you think we can sort of
build on that into the future and people
are Al ensuring you know it's amazing
and I either love less amazing history
we have on AI specifically actually yeah
but uh computer science in general yeah
I mean and it goes even broader than
that I mean you think about the
Industrial Revolution I mean just the
the number of inventions that happened
here right whether we all kind of
obviously know about Steam and then the
foreruns of electricity but the
mechanizing textiles a new process to
make steel
um you can go on and on I think even the
lawnmower was invented during that
period right so
that's our heritage
yeah I think actually the slightly kind
of the more interesting things if I
think about going forward a twofold one
is our approach to regulation I think
you know there's always when it comes to
technology and new businesses there's
balance to be struck between regulation
that supports Innovation but puts
appropriate protection in place
and I just think the UK is a track
record of getting that balance right and
not everyone does but I think the other
thing which probably is only going to
become more important is the fact that
we're also a global Powerhouse when it
comes to the creative side of things and
the creative Industries in the UK are
going like gangbusters I mean growing
twice as fast as the economy you think
the amount of wards we're winning
post-production and pre-production you
name it I mean this is a creative
industry's Powerhouse and not just film
and TV but everything on Advertising
marketing and all the rest gaming as you
mentioned and actually I just think as
as technology infuses the creative
industry is far more than it has in the
past again that just plays to our
strengths because there are very few
countries if any which punch at the
weight that we do when it comes to you
know creative Industries and and I think
that is a unique strength that we have
actually yeah I agree and just going
back to what you said earlier of
um also it's just about having the
ambition to to play at that Global stage
I think that's something we all don't
the audience can do more of and again I
think probably something you learned
over at Stanford and Silicon Valley and
I've been learning as well since
interacting with Google and just we can
you know we have all the ingredients
here we've got amazing world-class
universities incredible Talent poor
incredible Heritage we've just got to go
for it yeah I think that's right it's
about confidence right it's about
ambition having the ambition having the
confidence that you can realize those
Ambitions and you know success breeds
success your example deep Minds example
will hopefully Inspire others maybe here
today and you know when we're here in a
couple of years time we'll be
celebrating the next deep mind that's
how this is meant to work right exactly
so ai's we know we've been talking about
AI is obviously a huge strength for the
UK but of course we're also very good at
many other Technologies too what other
things excite you so I think the things
if I think about the big growth
industries in Tech AI semiconductors we
talked about engineering biology Quantum
those are probably the the tech sectors
that I think we need to make sure we're
well positioned for and I believe we are
um you know of all of those I think
probably Life Sciences is the one that
is particularly exciting and yes we have
Europe's biggest Life Sciences industry
we've got an incredible research base
but you saw during the pandemic not only
to be able to create a vaccine here we
also had a regulator that meant that we
were the first place to approve a
vaccine as well and it showed that the
agility that I think the UK is uh is
known for and then you combine that with
the unique strengths we have with the
biobank and genomic sequencing I mean
you know there's probably better than me
so be interesting to get your
perspective you know when I talk to
people around the world you know that's
an asset the biobank whether it's half a
million high quality database and also
strength and genomic sequencing
essentially doesn't exist anywhere right
so when you think about drug Discovery
or how can we push the boundary of
what's possible and how combined with
what you've done at Alpha fold you know
that seems to me to be incredibly
exciting but that you know this very
well no I 100 agree with you I think I
think that is of the most exciting
opportunity both I mean commercially and
also for the good of the world is is
what I we like to call digital biology I
mean the Advent of the new era where you
can do a lot of the exploration work in
silico with things like Alpha fold and
we spun out a new company called
isomorphic to sort of build on Alpha
fold Alpha folders uh uh you know finds
the structures of proteins but that's
only one small part of drug Discovery
and but I think that AI Technologies and
computational Technologies are going to
revolutionize drug Discovery and health
care in over the next decade so yeah
we're well positioned I think in the UK
to take advantage of that yeah and it's
what you were saying earlier it's
actually it's the application of things
like AI to all these other Industries
and it so happens that we're pretty good
in some of these other areas so when you
put together I think great things can
happen here that are not just good for
the economy right as you said it's great
creates jobs creates Prosperity but
these are things that can transform
Society I mean that's what's incredibly
exciting yeah fantastic great well I
think we've got a few questions from the
audience yeah so we've got some time
take some questions from the audience as
well so let's uh crack on who's got some
questions anybody
yes do you want to introduce yourselves
as well
prime minister thank
you thank you Global impact and yet
we're so lucky to have you in the UK so
thank you for choosing the UK to build
your business my question is one around
scale and pace of innovation and the
regulatory framework so we know that
because of the pace and the scale
International collaboration as we saw
with the vaccines International
collaboration is so vital for our UK
businesses to to drive and adopt you
know modern Technologies not just AI but
the ones you mentioned before so how how
in the UK are we planning to embed a
regulatory framework that can drive
Innovation and yet at the same time
balance I think some changing regulatory
Dynamics globally
Zara thanks
um you know it's it's not a formula
right but your question is exactly right
and it's what I've touched on it's
getting this balance right between
protection and safety and guard rails
but you know not throwing the baby out
of the bath water and making sure that
we continue to promote Innovation now I
said it it's not a formula it's just a
way that we approach these things I
think it you know comes as I said it
comes from the it probably stretches all
the way back to the enlightenment right
the Industrial Revolution and our
approach to these things which is
probably just in our cultural DNA which
is a great asset for the UK but I think
you know I think we approach things with
the principles first
um logic which I think is right and I
think that really helps us get the
regulation right I I think we're big on
engagement right and you know you're
sitting next to Chloe who's superb you
know I'm someone who takes this stuff
seriously so you've got a government
that is focused on engaging with
industry to make sure that we understand
how The Innovation is happening to make
sure we're creating a safe space for it
to happen regulatory sandboxes are a
good example of that in fintech demos
mentioned that is one of our strengths
the FCA was looking the first regulator
in the world to create a regulatory
sandbox that's now becoming a scale box
that's been exported around the world so
look I think you know that we've got a
good track record
um in doing that I think the other thing
I'd say is we've got to make sure that
the incentives and the environment is
right to diffuse the technology across
the economy because it's no point we
create these things and then and they
don't get spread so that the benefits
are not realized fully and I think
that's actually something that we
probably need to do a better job of
there's actually good academic research
the kind of diffusion of technology and
best practice across the economy in the
UK is probably a bit less than than is
optimal and less than other countries so
I think one thing we all need to keep an
eye on it's not just the incredibly
switched on Innovative people in this
room we should've got to figure out how
we spread that mindset to every small
all a medium-sized company everywhere in
the country because that's how you
really get the benefits of these things
realized I don't know yeah just just to
sort of touch on the point until that
International I think International
cooperation around AI is going to be
critical
um it's you know far too big a
Technologies for one country one company
you know it needs to be we all need to
come around to discuss this and it's and
to make sure we reap the benefits and
minimize the risks and I'm really
pleased the prime minister is is
supporting the global Summit and you
know in the Autumn uh well we'll
hopefully bring together World experts
from Academia industry and government
together to to talk about these
important topics but I think it's the
first step in an important Journey here
thank you right uh we got uh we've got
any other questions who have we got
is that sorry is it lady there yeah hi
good uh good morning prime minister
thank you Demus as well um Aaron Platts
CEO of the HSBC Innovation banking in
the UK so a very special day for us as
we launch our new brand
um and it's clear through what you
covered that we are all aligned in terms
of wanting to make the UK the best place
to start scale and invest in Innovation
and Life Sciences businesses but can you
talk a little bit more about what this
ecosystem should expect over the next
six to 12 months perhaps in the areas of
scale-up capital procurement to ensure
we continue on the journey to be a
global superpower
yeah thank you um Aaron but but also
thanks to HSBC because like I remember
that weekend vividly with regard to
Silicon Valley Bank and
it was great that we had an institution
that was prepared to step up quickly uh
to work with the government and other
partners to come and and rescue it and
make sure there was continuity of
funding for our ecosystem I think you
know you and your company deserve
enormous credit for that and it's great
that we're here celebrating the launch
of HSBC Innovation banking which
hopefully can become a big Global brand
and business supporting technology
businesses so thank you um you know what
can you expect from us I think you can
expect responsiveness as I said a
government that is listening and
engaging a government that gets it
because that's important
um but also a government that's working
at PACE right we are not in the business
of resting on our Laurels I think we get
that all of this is moving at a pace it
means government has to move at that
same pace and you've seen that in the
creation of this AI task force
but announced a little while ago now
that's going to be modeled on the
vaccine task force it's going to have
the agility and the flexible kind of
delegated authority to just do what it
needs to do build a leadership position
in in AI Safety Research ensure that we
have Sovereign capabilities where it
makes sense so I think that that's
that's the side of a government that's
doing things differently and acting a
little bit more like all of you in this
room and that's very much in you know
come from my own experience and and
career and I want to bring that same way
of thinking to government as well
and you know I think I guess the other
thing I'd say is you can see that in the
businesses that many of whom are here
who I guess voting with their feet you
know it's great to see just the other
week palantir announcing that their
Global AI research is going to be done
with European research is going to be
headquartered in London
you know the anthropic and open AI
adjoining Deep Mind and having their
European headquarters uh in the in the
UK and they just announced that a couple
of weeks ago and just today fantastic
news that one of the world's leading
Venture Capital firms injuries and
Horowitz is opening their first
International office here in the UK and
I think you know why why are they doing
that partly it's because they think not
all the things we've talked about but
particularly you know web 3 and
blockchain is another technology which
has enormous promise and you know they
see this as a place where that type of
research and Innovation is going to be
done in a very strong way so I think
that's all evidence of a government that
is doing all the things that I said and
you can see the outcomes because I think
companies are voting with their feet and
saying that the UK is where we want to
be
good um I think I'm conscious of time so
we probably need to take a couple of
questions from the from the media as
well
um so can I maybe start with the BBC if
they are here
hello Helen cat from the BBC How
concerned are you about the short-term
impact of AI on jobs given that we're
already seeing some losses and is Boris
Johnson undermining you and did anyone
at number 10 at any point meddled with
his honors list
out
so
on um on on your on your first question
look that's uh
I uh look it's an obvious when we think
about the rest of AI and what are people
worried about obviously you know
people's concern is for jobs and you've
had announcements where it started for
the first time you know AI is being
associated with how companies are are
reforming or restructuring their
workforces so obviously that's going to
be anxious for people
that we've we've grappled with these
things in the past I think MIT had a
interesting study that they'd done or
they looked at all the jobs of today and
discovered that I think 60 plus didn't
exist 30 40 years ago let's give you a
sense of something that we've had to
Grapple with before
um like I think it what does that mean
it means governments have to ensure that
everyone has access to education and
skills at every point in their lives and
that's what we're doing and we're
changing how we fund education so it's
not something that we think of as just
something that stops when you finish
school or college it's something that
you'll have to come back to and will
want to come back to wherever the course
of your entire career and dip in and out
of so I think that's that's incredibly
important plus making sure people in the
first place are set up to participate in
this new economy that is more focused on
technological skills and that's why I'm
very passionate about making sure people
study maths to 18 I think that you know
something where we're International
outlier and not doing that and I think
we need to do a better job of that for
all the benefits it will bring including
in the creative industries that I talked
about where the jobs are becoming even
more quantitative as well and look when
it when it comes to
you know honors and and Boris Johnson
Boris Johnson asked me to do something
that I wasn't prepared to do because I
didn't think it was right that was to
you know either overrule the holak
committee or to make promises with
people now I I wasn't prepared to do
that as I said I didn't think it was
right and if people don't like that then
tough
I um when I got this job
[Applause]
yeah when I when I got this job I said I
was going to do things differently
because I wanted to change politics and
that's what I'm doing and I'm also
Keen to make sure that we change how our
country works and that's what I'm here
talking about today making sure that we
can grow our economy that we can
maintain our leadership in the
Innovative industries of the future why
because it's going to create jobs for
people it's going to spread opportunity
around and it has the potential as we've
been discussing to transform people's
lives and as prime minister I want to
make sure that that happens because I
want to make sure that I improve
everyone's lives in this country and do
it in a way that is right and is in
accordance with my values and that's
what I'm going to keep doing
um
[Applause]
I think next we've got the times
thank you prime minister Mark Selman
from the times um we are hosting this
Summit in the Autumn uh about AI safety
do you believe that existential risk is
a reality in terms of uh one of the
risks of AI
um eventually down the track
yeah I look I I think I'm sitting next
to someone who's much better place to
answer this than me Mark um so I'll let
Dennis comment on that I look I think
there's there's a range of concerns
people have one is the socioeconomic
impact that we just talked about the
impact on people's jobs and then there
are there's obviously risks around
misuse right how do people use uh AI to
do things that are bad and people have
always used technology to do bad things
that's not a new thing we just need to
be alert to that
um there's kind of what we call tool use
and AI is a capability that provides uh
new opportunities for malicious actors
and then there's what I guess
technologists like Dennis would call
capability overhang which speaks to your
the kind of last category of risks that
then start to Trend into a space where
people are talking about very
significant risks that some would call
existential others would say alongside
things like pandemic to nuclear war and
that's obviously concerning and that's
why I think it's important that we put
guard rails in place to make sure that
we develop and exploit this technology
in a way that's safe and that is secure
that's why the summer is important
because it will bring together people to
consider those risks make sure that we
appropriately plan for them discuss the
right guard rails to put in place and
the research and evaluation that we're
going to need to do to make sure that
we're on top of it so I think those are
the kind of topics that I'm interested
in exploring at the summit but demos
would you ever yeah no so I agree with
all of that and and um you know I think
there are different we've talked about
incredible opportunities of AI I think
those everyone those understands those
well but there are attendant risks with
any new transformative technology and AI
is no different in that respect and I
agree with the prime minister's sort of
different buckets or categories of risk
and I think they need to be mitigated in
different ways from Bad actors using
these Technologies in bad ways that's a
sort of access issue to near-term risks
of like things like bias or deep fakes
and I think there are new technologies
along the way they're coming along like
encrypted watermarking which will help
with that and then there are these sort
of more long-term technical AI risks
things like alignment controllability
interpretability of these systems and I
think here it's it with this uncertainty
around those risks and we need to
understand research those systems a lot
more over the next few years to better
have a better handle on what the
boundaries are of these systems
including the risks and got and then we
can put the right guard rails in place
and government can put the right gold
rails in place so I think there's a uh
in the situation where there's a high
degree of uncertainty but a huge
potential impact either way I think the
only the right way to proceed is with
the precautionary principle you know be
proceed with exceptional care be
optimistic about what we can do with the
opportunities and and sort of use things
like the scientific methods to study and
carefully analyze these systems as they
get increasingly more powerful in the
future brilliant thanks Dennis and then
lastly Bloomberg
hi Celia from Bloomberg
um my question is why would uh AI people
decide to come to the U K and K to a to
a UK
scheme when you have a much larger
training block like the EU going ahead
with their own AI regulation
great so that's a good question to end
on because it speaks to everything that
we've been talking about for the last uh
half hour or so and that's about the UK
just having confidence in itself the UK
is one of the leading places in the
world for AI as we are in so many other
strengths not not me saying that that's
the facts look at the AI research
capability that we have here the number
of citation citations and AI research
that's produced you know essentially
after the U.S where the leading
Democratic power when it comes to the
quality of our AI research base look at
the number of AI companies that we have
here a third of all of Europe's
companies are here I think twice as many
as anywhere else in Europe look at the
money raised same and then look at the
companies themselves right as we just
talked about you know there's three
Frontier Labs
Dennis's headquartered here Google have
headquartered their AI business here
under Dennis's leadership but then
anthropic and open AI have just opened
their European offices where they've
opened them here in the UK you've got
palantir just opening their Global AI
research capability here in the UK and
so look those are all the reasons we
should feel confident and optimistic
about our lead in Ai and our ability to
play a leadership role and the creation
of the task force with more funding than
anywhere else in the world for Safety
Research again is a reason why I think
we can play a leadership role in is we
can develop all the evaluations and the
auditing that that Demis talked about
we're going to steal a march on that and
get going with that quickly but look
this is not about imposing our view of
the world on everyone else right this is
that this is about convening people and
bringing them together Academia business
governments from around the world AI
doesn't respect National borders this is
about us just bringing people together
to talk through these issues together
and ultimately put in place a
multilateral framework because that's
what it's going to require ultimately
but do I think the UK can be a leader in
shaping that conversation absolutely I
do right because we've got incredible
strengths here and we shouldn't be shy
about that right we should be confident
in our ability to to lead this
conversation because it's incredibly
important that we get it right it's
going to be incredibly important for the
future of our country we want all the
benefits that AI can bring but we need
to manage it safely you know that's my
job as prime minister and we're going to
do it working together and I'm very
grateful to Demis as well for his
support but you know I think we can have
a very exciting Summit which is going to
produce some really important outcomes
not just for the UK but for the World At
Large
great I think that's what we've got time
for so thank you prime minister for all
your valuable time and support look
forward to getting right with you
[Applause]